we'll all be together in person soon
okay ready okay we want to get him
involved in nutrition
okay good he cares deeply about that
that'd be great
okay let us get ready so
um tom if you will put your right hand
raise your right hand and put your
hand on your left hand on the bible okay
and repeat after me
i thomas j vilsack hi thomas j vilsack
do you solemnly swear do you solemnly
swear that i will support and defend
the constitution of the united states
that i will support and defend
the constitution of the united states
against all enemies foreign and domestic
against all enemies foreign and domestic
that i will bear
true faith and allegiance to the same i
will bear
true faith and allegiance to the same
that i take this obligation freely
i take this obligation freely without
any mental
reservation or purpose of evasion
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that i will well and faithfully
discharge
and that i will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office
upon which i am about to enter the
duties of the office upon which i am
about to enter
so help me god so help me god
congratulations mr secretary
congratulations and to the whole family
congratulations to everybody
congratulations and i will see you guys
soon the president is so excited
so to the whole family congratulations
we've got a lot of work to do and we'll
do it together and christy again it's
great to see you as well
okay enjoy enjoy
you